sentez toujours vous avez peut-être
découvert dans la presse cette semaine
cette campagne pour les fruits et
légumes
il s'agit de convaincre de leurs
bienfaits campagne menée par la sécurité
sociale delphine horvilleur didier morel
et le matin vous pouvez manger un
pamplemousse est délicieuse a dès le
matin pour démarrer la journée
c'est un portsmouth 1 pamplemousse
pourquoi pas vous avez le choix
l'important selon les nutritionnistes
c'est de manger au moins cinq fruits et
légumes par jour pour profiter de tous
leurs bienfaits
il va y avoir beaucoup plus d'amis bêta
carotène polyphénols vitamine c vitamine
e autant d'éléments propriétés médicales
reconnues aux études ont montré que en
augmentant la consommation de fruits et
légumes ont diminué ce les risques de
contracter un son de maladies notamment
donc les cancers littéraires sont deux
maladies cardiovasculaires l'obésité le
diabète
au palmarès des fruits les grands
gagnants restent dans l'ordre les pommes
les mandarines et les oranges mais le
raisin cette saison pourrait bien
détrôner c'est incontournable
c'est en tout cas l'avis de certains
gourmands